alright guys I yeah it's your boy
psychobabble here with mr. Donald Trump
right here okay we're gonna play another
mission um and this one is in the memory
dance so let's do this okay I'd love
memories memories are God watching check
out let's go you don't look like you
need the memory dead do you even know
what we do there is something about
memories glad to meet someone who pays
attention to the name that's right we
let you live oh good I need to turn such
a clever boy away but we aren't
accepting new clients right now let me
persuade this [ __ ] you're cautious I
respect that but I think I can handle it
if you'll just give me a chance I'm
sorry we have to be very selective and
we're just not looking for new clients
now oh ok ok let's bribe those bad
things free I know how it is what if i
paid a hundred caps up front persistence
and money two things I what's up with
our hair line [ __ ] it I give you a trial
ah can it ever a most involving other
people are easiest recent events
involving loved ones does anything come
to mind my wife my wife died recently
chub just get another one hit like 10 oh
honey I'm so sorry it's never easy
losing someone that close to you oh yeah
yeah but I think we can Oh cut cut this
I'm here sit down in the lounger let's
see what memory we can okay the memory
dad let's do this sighs ugh i don't know
you can come with me and this one sister
launcher which one of those ears
that's dr. Amari
our client is what married see if you
can find a memory of the spouse all
right scanning the hippocampus okkk very
recent the sync with the temporal lobes
is strong that's the one this is hurt
nanny it's show time ooh oh is this
gonna be one of my recent wet dreams I
hope they don't link it to that cuz I
have a lot of wet dreams oh this is such
a bad one oh my god your ball computers
are still working on much to see you
checking through the log you that's the
guy it's almost are you fine ponci six
down the hall near the end now now
yeah they got tangled on there I'm other
way oh my god Nora I can't watch this
again how could you isn't it was here
oh yes [ __ ]
uh-huh everything's going to be fine uh
very very persuasive let the boy go ah
Cheh us she says his eyes
mustache man
Richard Gere
ear my ear it dog I got dogged cook here
we [ __ ] up dog [ __ ] gone nuts Jesus
sorry if I had any idea that we were
going to put you through that again I
would have said no
well isn't there any other memory you
could have found I told you we find the
clearest memory we can for the first
time that one stood out Shehu need help
sweetheart and I know just the man whose
name of Nick balance no way works out of
diamond city these days if anyone can
help you find your missing child it'll
be him oh okay quick mission quick
question okay well thanks for watching
us thank you